we we have many videos on the
end uh but still it eludes us okay his
elbow has to be on the front side of my
spine so here's my spine line okay his
elbow can't be on
the spine definitely not on the other
side you won't have the
engine capable of dealing with the
pin his elbows on the front side
and then the pin is not in my waist cuz
nothing's in my waist it's not in my
arms because nothing should be in my
arms so I'll do my
qua and then I'll turn my tonden forward
down because it's K hole here which is
what it is it's K hole it's not a pin
because here in
modern this is nothing more than the
Kimura and nothing stopping
the forward
roll
okay so for
example if I was doing the omop Plata
which is the same thing I got to stop
that ability to roll then I get the
LW this is koku
hul this is where I turn the
tonden into this forward cycle
down okay so I turn the quaw and then I
drop
it got it that's what I'm doing it's
cul because it's
concentric the the art is
concentric it is how to do a lock on the
shoulder mechanism so what I'm doing
here is not an elbow
elbow but I'm going to take this scapula
mechanism move it
forward and
down okay so if I'm if I'm here like
this and I'm moving it forward and down
and I get another lock
going then I'll have a pin try to roll I
can't
okay so I am doing a shoulder lock is
just this is not a pin like you use a
shoulder lock and use cou hole
okay so get it in the right place let's
turn this
way to free your
mind because it's not a
pin and it's K hole
I'm not going to turn my waist I'm not
going to use my
arms I understand what I'm trying to do
to the shoulder
mechanism only this knee is
important this knee is not
important meaning it does not have to
be pinching his
shoulders as if that did anything
magical okay um so here I
am the elbows on my center line or even
over I have my magic hands and I'm
pitching his shoulder and just stand up
Sean
okay what this knee
does it does not need the other knee for
is it stops him going for
forward so that KNE is there elbows in
front turn the qua and then rotate the
tanden
forward and you'll get the pin okay all
right let's try
it so the whole time you're training you
have releasing they're they're just
releasing drills really but especially
on the UK side okay um so as as I go do
you see me
here okay I'm going to one stay there
once I press I felt my own tomen form
you see as the two y energies are
hitting each other so now I keep that
feeling in my
body and I don't lose it
tension in the limbs is going to make me
lose
[Music]
it the mat is Young energy
too you see
I have to
reconcile with the mat as
well
no
smooth
accepting
releasing all
right hey there is no
pain you're in you're resisting the pain
shows up okay try again